曲もいいよはいというわけで今日はですねー
ドンキホーテにも目に入る分のあらゆる芳香剤をここにはありますこれが多分ドンキで
売ってる
もう古材のすべてですおそらく今日は何をしようかといったら
っ子ちらの芳香剤を全部1回開封してフェイした状態でここに全部おきます何個あんの
123456やシェ40
の第50個くらいの芳香剤ここにありますでなんかに消臭元とかわね徴収するもんなん
だけど匂いがあるから
これに良い内の匂いがあるね上芳香剤っていうカウントにしておきます
なぜその芳香剤家らによって臭いが少数意見に吸収された臭いはしないかも知れません
それは分かりません
芳香剤約50種類を全部開封したのはここにおいてこの部屋を密閉しなぐらいは見ずし
て3時間後に帰ってきた時のこの部屋のね
いよいよ
確かめると思います芳香剤でね動画に行くのね
エンターテーメントを出せることでね一種の芳香剤の大革命と言っても過言ではない
このイベントでございますというわけで
早速ね芳香剤全部開封していきましょうん
ああああああ
終わりましたーーー
合剤好かん
ていません
がそないな人が知り合いでしたこれはえん
さう
散歩れギャバいえ溶けるんじゃぬあたな痛くなってきたしもう
入ってあげる終わりましたん
もうなんかもう頭に退出
ファッ
いやもう八枚ずつけど頭突きと
頭突きじゃねーわ頭痛と寒気がも販売するハトメてても意味ないと思うんだずにゃん
好き配置しますこれかもよ
はい10月今から未だに時半なんですけど3時間ぐらいすれば前にするかな
橙子チャーハン御山くらいにこの部屋に帰ってきます
性周期が打ち勝ちいいのになってるかもうどくガスが蔓延してこういうずになって買っ
てね
で3時間後にお会いしましょう
やはりもうやばいもうヤバいー
ん
あ
さっき
しています